welcome to Hawaii the show were I don't
really ask you what to do next week I
just react about your memes that more or
less relate to me let's go leave your
clothes the ultimate start when you buy
eight Wi-Fi routers to make a meme
because it's cheaper than buying editing
software stinks
well played I applaud your dummy
dumbness you can literally just ask all
your friends to hotspot and change the
name of your phone of your hotspot
this is stupid stinky brain down vote
you don't have to buy eight routers you
dummy them unless they pretended that
they bought eight routers to legitimize
the meme I will upload it so for now the
pp is inconclusive okay
do you think your wife tena deserve
crater of the year no mr. beast should
have wanted
thanks Satan I mean I had a pretty good
year too this whole subreddit is like
mr. BAE's is the best I love he is I'm
kidding
when your memes never make it to Louie
but your name made it first half second
a pathetic victory is still victory
can't tell if small or big VP hmm it's
small for no reason at all 87 year old
ran my shows hurt 3,500 plus our Animal
Crossing town goddamn an 87 year old
grandma is more of gamer than you
pathetic I will personally confront
everyone who dislike this agreed damn
see this is why I think Rick being
retired is gonna be awesome so you'll
have so many epic games to play I'm
gonna be in VR on one of those Japanese
toilets where I don't have to wipe and
I'm gonna have food delivered in my
mouth and I'm just gonna sit there with
my giant 20 arms well I would do cool
stuff not that that's cool beating
minecraft by walking only in a straight
line terraria players first time
pathetic
this is this YouTube right now hey guys
I made this pointless challenge in
Minecraft oh wow this is so wacky and
crazy oh cool
you're not supposed to play the game
like this I'm alright send PewDiePie
picture of my freakin plop plop for
Christmas what do you think he'll
respond with oh my god PewDiePie
delivered Oh what am I supposed to
respond to that Jesus Christ Netflix you
little flirt topic for me you just
shooting my shot
just watch a me-too movement for Netflix
it's coming it's inevitable rewind this
decade yes or no warning this may cost
tear to fall oh I bet there Plutonians
[Music]
yeah
damn that's nuts dude very nice at it
big peepee not gonna lie
loading in third perspective no that's
lauding nodding you like you are nodding
I loved it for you here we go loading I
like have someone actually thought of
like a clever it's a clever concept
right you understand it it's a good meme
people up on it but you can't spell
loading and no one's calling you out on
it
bahding hilarious girls
where's boys closed everyone so cute boy
where's girl code that game no it's so
unfair yeah what is that oh I guess I
was wrong yikes cat's official trailer
this is what the people in the bird box
saw before they die man
yeah I heard cats is like a fever dream
to watch oh my god if life is a video
game the graphics are great but the plot
is confusing and the tutorial is way too
long if life is a video game the plot is
extremely boring and dragged out and the
payoff isn't that good in the end and
all the side characters are so annoying
truth hurts ready it's just social media
for people who think they're too smart
for social media never before have I
been so offended by something i 100%
agree with i can't really fault that i
can't really fault that peers are saying
i have big PP me being a girl
big PP people that walk fast are
reported to be less happy the problem of
being faster than light is that you can
only live in darkness the problem with
being faster than light is that it's
physically impossible so go [ __ ]
yourself sonic yeah I can see that it
seems like in big cities when people are
in a rush that's why I don't like a lot
of big cities cuz we I don't know
especially London people are so rude I
can see people like that being miserable
in 1953 due to high speed the eff Allah
hears the say me
the f/11 fighter shot itself because it
was what no like how people in the
comments are arguing whether this is
real or not this is some heated
conversation I like him young and
innocent Stage six stages of growing up
awkward and there's I mean I'm grown-up
awkward and coughs age yeah remember
that dank and a gteen stage we don't
talk about this stage Thank You adult
with existential crisis stage boomer
stage def stage can wait hmm would you
take a moment oh here we go
this one I swear the summary this is
gonna be mr. B's mr. B's is so good I
love mr. B's so much mr. B's saved my
life
would you take a moment and appreciate
what Jimmy has done for us it's hard to
believe that he planned the 20 million
trees gave a house to random pizza
delivery guy
Gammage found a million dollar and
changed many people's life thanks Jimmy
thanks Jimmy oh no this sub is going to
[ __ ] it's turned to karma whoring Reaper
see I don't even know what karma whoring
is this is why I'm glad I'm a Boomer
repost we've always had reversed and
feuds unrelated post oh really why me
what the muds don't care they don't care
Pizza call people out on it and still
hasn't changed I know this is going to
get lost in new also self-deprecating
but we need to stop this sub is now
awful it's not our means our denk means
go push means there can we go back to
the good old days of awesome fan arts
not five minutes scribbles I don't think
people would like this to just be fan
art it's nice to see every once in a
while no one would use this it was just
fan art that's a weird metric of its
being better I I'm sure this person has
good reasons to feel the way they do but
I found in general as someone that's run
communities for a long time on the
Internet
after a certain while people just tend
to complain and a lot of times it
doesn't seem completely funded I would
say I remember mild forum back in the
day the exact same thing happened like
it was it was a fun space and then he
grew bigger and big and then people like
it sucks now because before it was
better because fine art
people complaining doesn't help either
Lawai is fine I would rather see a
caramel whoring post than people
complaining to be honest after all these
years I finally have them all discord
ready okay I take it back this person is
right oh god you're right now I see it I
can't unsee it I still have fun
reviewing it so I don't care if my crowd
world is infinite how does the Sun get
around everyone at Mojang everyone emoji
and be like oh my god even much he's
onto us please send nudes placin nudes
Pleasants pewds that's a pretty pie meme
and it's good alright for now on I will
upload what is really important for the
subreddit big pay P don't worry guys I
fixed it can this video get the same
likes as the in dislikes oh my god big P
P big P I'm handing them out left and
right
the power is mine alone oh there's
someone else doing the same joke babe a
babe definitely a trilled me turning on
the car like my dad holo and Anakin
you're gonna get us both killed
prequel mean and relevant meme at the
same time big PP well done I checked
this on Marzia few days ago I turn on
the lights just to see how she would
react and she wanted to turn it off it's
one of those things that everyone was
just taught not to do it for whatever
reason and then we both laugh how stupid
it was cuz once you realize like yeah
why why why is that an issue I think I
know why though I think I know why
because they're not automatic now the
car lights are automatic right so the
thing is like the kids in the back
forget them on right they click um when
it's dark and then they leave the car
but then the light is on during the day
which is annoying and then the parent
has to go back in the car to turn up the
light that's why they said it was
illegal it isn't actually legal guys
like I'm pretty sure pretty sure at
least don't take my word for it like if
you go to jail for it I can't help you
but I'm pretty sure her you okay Polly
come on how are you not looking at doggy
we're spring in Edgar's ear going there
I'm gonna [ __ ] murder their Bunch
Oh scare that is so good no we had a
great Christmas okay
oh by the way big PP forgot big PP I
think this is just some natural
awkwardness that's right the flash I'm
the fastest man alive the camera man are
you challenging me oh that's a good
point actually I never thought of that
how'd this camera follow them huh I do
hate this I don't know why I hate this
Scooby Doo mean so I'm downloading it
and I got a voice crack while I did it
so I think that naturalizes it media
study shows that video games cause
violence me which study media well I
don't freaking know what how am I
supposed to know that
it's toads video games that causes all
those violence in America we watched
that movie yesterday what was it called
mid-90s have you seen that it's a movie
about growing up in the 90s where these
really young kids goes out drinking
doing drugs car crashes and drunk
driving accidents while falling on
skateboards all these crazy stuff and
you're like maybe maybe letting kids
play video games isn't so bad all right
parents it could be like it used to be a
lot worse if the only difference that is
that they parents see the kids and
they're like oh my god they play game
with the stinky stinky boomers be quiet
I said it be quiet boomer PewDiePie I
think I almost discovered everything in
terraria terraria veterans watching PD
PI it's weird it always feels like I'm
done with the game I do think I should
probably end the series though because
I'm going on a break soon and I think it
would be awkward for me to come back
into it even though I do enjoy terraria
but I'm sorry it's over senpai of poor
what is your wish to this sub reddit has
GOG gadget it madly made every pouch see
this is thing I think the reason I don't
like this impulse is because alright
don't don't get personally attacked okay
I don't get personally attacked but
people don't know what to think I'm not
talking about you I'm saying as a group
it's one thing I learned about being
half in charge of a group on the
internet they can't think for themselves
a lot of them can't think for themselves
so when people start saying oh this has
gone edition it kind of spirals out of
the way and then people don't even know
why they think that they just heard that
other people said it's like oh it
some read it to me since the same as it
always been if you have any ideas on how
to improve it by all means but just
complaining it's just stupid to me I've
seen this happen so many times that to
know when it doesn't mean anything
all right so small PP that's so cool
know this so Bridget has gone to guys
can't you tell that's not I feel like I
should this should be could you make me
like an animation of this without the
background so I can use it in my videos
mr. Finn Bo because everyone else does
that so I feel like I have to do that
now sighs can you edit this in so this
is in the video so to remind people to
like the video yeah there it is all
right we have another one where I put
doggie on top of his head is so funny it
looks like dog is riding edgar your mom
gate ro whoa delivery guys working on
the 1st of January everyone where have
you been I ordered the last decade
delivery guys it's so funny that I
forgot to laugh thank you yeah that's
probably my least favorite type of humor
when someone says something that doesn't
really make sense and then you're like
oh get it nobody Newton's third law of
motion you bite the fry the fry bites
back man that's funny
only physicists 19 year olds will
understand if you can read this then
we're in the same boat I can't sleep how
can you not see that are you blind
you can't hurt me because I'm already
broken inside 19 year old big peepee
that's a billy Elish level of deepness I
am 19 this is deep oh my God look at all
these karma [ __ ] oh my god mother hits
teenage daughter with flip-flop from
impossibly long distance damn I respect
that
impossibly long just like my peepee and
whoever made this mean well done
what's that the bite of 87
was that the meme of 87 was that the
approach of 87 the only boomers we can
respect don't know who that is
I'm not fine I'm a Boomer so I saw these
on Facebook should we believe him new
[Laughter]
boots enjoying being with his friends a
random 19 year old is madness it hasn't
happened yet
and I've taken a lot of selfies from
last week okay disappointed disappointed
I think I've done this similar one time
before where I said if you meet me say
this and then someone met me and they're
like oh god I know I'm supposed to say
something but I forgot what it is and
then I brofist in their face and I said
remember it next time but [ __ ] that
didn't actually happen by the way the
PewDiePie Draper shake oh my god I
didn't even register it I am a train
boys day yes like big peepee oh thank
you can you build me that and send it to
me so I can shoot people from distance
and kill for those who don't know it's a
dream of mine to be a trebuchet I've
always dreamt about it when I play Age
of Empires I always go only trebuchet
only trebuchet damn god damn are they
sweet based on Swedish portraits that's
awesome very nice big BB a photographer
took pictures of people before it after
she called them beautiful
god that's funny oh this could be the
area 51 successor we recreate the
seven-mile spanking machine from Sponge
Bob spanking machine is that what they
did that's illegal
this should not be making me laugh this
is so bad oh my god it's beautiful
I'm such a big fan oh my god is map
related to science I swear someone says
to me that to me I'm gonna be like why
what are you talking about I'm such an
idiot
it's mad for later this I wouldn't stop
it what's wrong with you petition for
peopIe to do a collab with Felix
Kjellberg oh my god I love Phyllis
Cadell burg he's my favorite youtuber he
links should sort by new and Lawai so
you can react to the god-awful memes
there oh that makes me curious
alright
new Serpine new let's go oh god oh god
makes me with pneumatic nomadic absurd
watermark and me
shop shop made with big peepee big
peepee that's not so bad
naw small peepee that's kind of amusing
oh god there's so many repost I mean if
I laugh I have that boat god damn it
honestly I expected a lot worse I
expected a lot worse can we take a
moment to appreciate cipher working hard
and video effects and adding legs for
pills shoutout to scythe moment thank
you so good that CGI he blends the blur
in the shadows aware what Felix should
play happy with one last time in the
second because I don't flash players
going to shut down
I guess I'm forced to play it now the
final video of this decade will be happy
wheels prepare yourself it's going to be
imagine your pose make it Tula why this
post was made by me
wow you're dead it smoked PP but at what
cost
I made the / dank means banner imputes
showed it and I am so happy not so sweet
I'm glad you were happy by that it's a
good banner wish ours was that good
Felix son mommy mommy can you show me
daddy's old photos marzia here here have
a look at this this is the kind of
complainings I like because it's funny
at least imagine being creative this
pose is made by Peter Pan submission
gang big baby
imagine having to click your phone twice
to like a picture this pose was made by
reddit gang small PP me my friend remade
this for some reason that's pretty good
hey we got some fan art big PP that's
cool I pretty pie will show you small
brain fools the true power of my stand
lasagna oh I get it is this full metal
alchemist reference that's so cool
I love my favorite anime because Edgar
is the robot right
I appreciate the groin very nice big
paper very nice very nice
hey boots we're still waiting for this
year class it's reviewed this year is
about to end hurry up I mean trying to
buy less clothes just because I'm gonna
move
anyway so that wouldn't be much to show
I'm sorry
imagine having to censor all your words
now Frick this post was made by Stream
gang big P P P T PI when he slams his
hand on his desk while reading any any
change at night ok guys hope you enjoyed
that episode of the BA smash like
subscribe this is the last lie of the
decade and I want to take this time to
say thank you for all the love why I
know people don't like it as much as
they do and maybe it's not so big VP
maybe some people get small PP but I
just want to say you should be happy
even if you have a small beat you take
it for someone that knows I'm just
kidding alright bye
[Music]
the hour of our spells and poop grades
is coming
marzia Edgar and putouts need you
the timer you will face but crawlers is
all about
when you are seated on the porcelain
throne booty is the game to play I'm not
supposed to have my opinion about that
but the prizes
[Music]
you